the Demeter
out at Sea with no land in sight this
story takes place on this merchant ship
the Demeter we started our Voyage doing
the Interiors of the ship in Berlin it's
a fantastic studio we had one set it was
on rockers it went back and forth it was
kind of getting seasick but we're on the
set and then we had to shift this huge
company of people to the island of Malta
the biggest ship that's ever been built
in Malta it's 180 feet long yeah it's a
huge achievement and we have this
Infinity tank that looks out into the
Mediterranean and so they built the
exterior of the ship in this tank we
want to give the cast best performance
opportunity they can you know and so to
build it where you can see the water
will you know help inform the
performances and give you a much better
movie
and he's coming
it's got a massive bar just full of air
tanks which when we fill them with water
and air at the same time make the ship
list from the port of starboard
evil isn't bored powerful evil I wanted
the ship to feel dirty and real it was
built with old material to make sure
that it felt grounded head all the ropes
made all the pulleys made so it really
is sort of endless detail we had this
whole set that we could make our
playground and that scale really does
help in creating that world make God
have mercy on us all